[Music]
you need to prove you're looking for
work
I've been looking trust me three
signatures by tomorrow or you can tell
it to the judge
tell me about a time when you worked
hard to solve a problem this morning
getting up we're gonna find you someone
you like
let me be your arms and your legs I love
all right
penthouse you need to wait your turn
relax it's not a holdup just sign this
one please oh what'd I say I don't know
slowly what don't your arms work they
don't you can move your mouth as can you
I need assistance misses a peg hell yeah
you are not qualified for this position
have you changed your catheter
pinch the head insert me I can't feel it
oh well I can't gonna feed your soul and
listen to it school
thank thank think about what you're
trying to do to me it's amazing it
sounds just like ya it's uncanny
he was rich is jay-z no Richard
which caused us all of these to the
right oh yeah they're not practical
exactly
you can have any girl you want for box
later on Botox and be punished for each
other you can't move your body she can't
move her face I specifically said
nothing for my birthday I'm sorry you
gotta have a surprise party in your huge
mansion
someone's got real problems I'm fighting
to see my son and whose fault is it is
it yours or is the world how to get you
mad I'm gonna break this big-ass bottle
one tell made a mess
[Music]
[Music]
this is me baby relax
[Music]